[Music]
a long time ago in the United States of
America the emperor of politics created
two political parties the anti
Republicans and the anti Democrats and
he asked them each to choose a mascot
the anti Republicans said we want to be
a donkey amber said fine you're a donkey
and the anti Democrats said we want to
be an elephant the Emperor said fine
you're an elephant but the donkey said
hey wait a second if they're gonna be an
elephant we don't want to be a donkey
that's not a fair fight and there's
gonna be all kinds of jokes about us
being an ass can't we be something cool
like a lion or a buffalo even a bunny
rabbits cooler than a donkey but the
Emperor of politics said no
unfortunately it's like choosing the
thimble in monopoly it might seem cool
and ironic at first but then you're
stuck with it for the rest of the game
and the donkey said fine and then he
asked so what do we believe in it
doesn't matter just pick some stuff as
long as you guys can't stand each other
and then the elephant said but what if
we believe in the same thing then find a
way to argue about it and make it seem
like you don't the emperor paused for a
moment and then said there's one more
thing donkey I'm taking away your balls
though the donkey was like what and the
elephant was like hey you're a donkey
with no balls and the Emperor said and
you elephant oh crap I'm gonna take away
your harp though and the donkey said hey
man why you got to take away my balls in
his heart because you're politicians and
it's punishment for all the lies you're
gonna be telling from now on in addition
every four years you're gonna have to
get together and try to convince
everyone that you have what I just took
away from you the donkey and the
elephant were quiet for a moment and
then the elephant said so what are you
gonna do with my heart and his balls and
the Emperor said oh those I'm gonna give
those to the American people they're
gonna do the real work anyways and they
know they need a little bit
[Music]